[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمل وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعلون
البدايه من فيلم اقرب نقطه من حدود
ليتوانيا مع روسيا حيث القمه المرتقبه
لحلف شمال الاطلسي
وهذه الصور المباشره من موسكو التي تجدد
منها التحذير من استمرار الدعم العسكري
الغربي
ومن الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور حيث قال
مراسل الجزيره ان اشتباكات ضاريه بالاسلحه
الثقيله اندلعت بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه الكلاكله الجنوبيه
العاصمه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا بالدفع بمجموعات
مرتزقه جدد بديل لتعويض الخسائر في باخموت
وموسكو تعلن صد هجمات اوكرانيه على محاور
دونيسكو وزابولوجيا ولوجانسك وتعرض
بالجورود لعشرات القذائف
في انتقاد امريكي علنيل سياسات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بايدن يدعون تنياهو للتغيير
نحو الاعتدال ويشدد على ان سياسات اسرائيل
جزء من المشكله في الضفه الغربيه
نتنياهو يدافع عن نهجه الامني في التعامل
مع الفلسطينيين وزير ماليته يعلن رفض
تحويل اي اموال لسلطه الفلسطينيه
وبنغفير يقول ان على بايدن ان يدرك ان
اسرائيل ليست جزءا من الولايات المتحده
اجتماع للجنه الايجاد بشان السودان بحضور
ممثلين عن الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع انفجارات ضخمه تهز جنوبي الخرطوم
وام درمان ومع احتضان الاشتباكات في
الابيض عاصمه ولايه شمال كردفان قوات
الحركه الشعبيه شمال تسيطر على معسكر
للجيش بمنطقه قريظ بولايه جنوب كردوفان
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تفاقم ازمه اللجوء
وطالبي اللجوء في تونس بعد فقدان عشره
مهاجرين غير نظاميين وانتشالي جثه واحده
بعد غرض مركبهم على سواحل جرجيس مما يرفع
عدد القتلى الى اكثر من 600 منذ بدايه
العام لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما
اسباب تفاقم ازمه الطالبين اللجوء في تونس
خمسه وخمسون في المئه قالوا ان سبب يعود
لعدم نجاعه سياسات الحكوميه في احتوائها
بينما قال 45% ان تدفق اللاجئين باعداد
كبيره يفوق قدره السلطات هذا سؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر
على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
نزور توتر في البوسنه والهرسك بعد دخول
قانونين مثيرين للجدل وقعهما زعيم صرب
البوسنه احدهما يلغي سلطه الممثل السامي
الدولي داخل الكيان الصربي
[موسيقى]
الان ام ليس بعد
طموحك بالاطلسي سيبحث في فيرنيوس يضغط
الاوكرانيون لانتزاع تعهد من قمه النيتو
بمنحهم مسار الانضمام السريع على خطى
فنلندا والسويد او وعد بتلقي دعوه
للانضمام الى الحلف بعد انتهاء الحرب
ربما زادت غبطه الرئيس الاوكراني
بعد الكلمات الطيبه التي سمعها من الشركاء
في جولته الاوروبيه الشرقيه الاخيره
وبما قيل له تحديدا في تركيا عن استحقاق
بلاده عضويه حلف شمال الاطلسي لكن واشنطن
لا تستعجل كما يبدو فتح باب النيتو امام
كييف
لا اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين مستعدون للانضمام
الى النيتو لقد بذلت وقتا طويلا في محاوله
الحفاظ على تماسك الحلف ولا اعتقد ايضا ان
هناك اجماعا في النيتو حول ما اذا كان
سيتم ضم اوكرانيا الى عضويته ونحن في خضم
الحرب فان نحن فعلنا ذلك الان سنكون
ملزمين بالدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضي الحلف
وسنكون جميعا في حاله حرب مع روسيا
يقول بايدن ذلك ولما تهدا بعد الزوبعه
التي اثارها قرار ادارته تزويد اوكرانيا
بدخائر عنقوديه لاستخدامها على الارجح في
هجومها المضاد الذي مر عليه شهر واكثر
انها اسلحه تلقى انتقادات واسعه لانها
تقتل عشوائيا من خلال نظام يطلق مجموعه من
الذخائر المتفجره الاصغر حجمه وهي مصممه
للانفجار قبل الارتطام او عنده او بعده
وتتسبب بمقتل العديد من المدنيين
نتحدث عن ذخائر محظوره من معظم اعضاء
النيتو لكن الولايات المتحده تواصل
استخدامها لا يبدو ان الخلافه حول هذه
المساله سينال من الاصرار الغربي على
المضي في دعم اوكرانيا لكن يبدو ان دعمها
عسكريا شيء والاسراع بضمها الى التحالف
العسكري الغربي شيء اخر فهل بالاول يستعاد
عن الثاني
تعول اوكرانيا اساسا على دعم دول اوروبا
الشرقيه الاعضاء في النيتو لاصدار جدول
واضح لضمها للحلف وبينما تتنقل بريطانيا
بين الدعم والوساطه تجنح الولايات المتحده
والمانيا وقياده الحلف للدعم الحذر مع
الاخذ في الحسبان انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو
لن يكون ممكنا الا بعد انتهاء الحرب
الروسيه عليها
ليس هذا الجدل كله ما تود روسيا يبحثه
قاده حلف شمال الاطلسي في قمه ليتوانيا
بل ما تصفه موسكو بالتاثير المدمر
والعواقب السلبيه لاستمرار الامداد
العسكري
وقبل ذلك ما تقول المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه انه الحاقك ضررا ممنهجا بمحطه
النوويه ماريا اوضحت ان الاغلبيه العظمى
من دول الحلف ستكون في المنطقه المتاثره
بشكل مباشر اذا وقعت كارثه في المحطه
ميدانيا في اوكرانيا فدى مراسل الجزيره
باندلاع اشتباكات عنيفه وقصف متبادل بين
الجانبين الاوكراني والروسي في محيط مدينه
وقالت مصادر محليه في المنطقه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحرز تقدما ملحوظا في المحور
الجنوبي لمدينه باخموت وفي شمال شرقي
البلاد قال حاكم مقاطعه خاركيد ان القوات
الروسيه شنت غارات جويه على عدد من
البلدات الحدوديه ما ادى الى تضرر عدد من
المنازل
وقال مناسق العمليات والناطق باسم قياده
المنطقه الشرقيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
للجزيره ان التصريحات الروسيه بشان
استخدام اسلحه كيميائيه في باك موت ملفقه
واضاف ان قواته تحرز تقدما في محور باخموت
وان الامر لم يحسم بعد في كلاشيفكا واشار
المسؤول العسكري الاوكراني الى ان الجيش
الروسي دفع بارتال لاسترداد ما خسره في
باخموت مؤكدا ان الجيش الاوكراني يحافظ
على كل ما سيطر عليه من مواقع وانه افشل
محاولات الروس لاستردادها ولفت الى ان
الجيش الروسي دفع بمجموعات من مرتزقه جدد
لا ينتمون لفاجنر
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها صدت
جميع محاولات الهجوم الاوكرانيه في محاور
دونيسكو وزابولوجيا والوجانسك وقال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور كوناشينكوف ان
القوات الروسيه دمرت مستودعات ذخيره
فيروجيا
نظريه كما قال العلم غرامه نجحت قوتنا في
صد هجمات العدو بجمهوريه دونيتسك الشعبيه
وتم القضاء على نحو 180 عنصرا من القوات
الاوكرانيه والمرتزقه الاجانب وتدمير
اليات عسكريه ومدافع ومنصه مدفعيه امريكيه
الصنع كما دمرت قواتنا مستودعات ظهيره
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقتي كارلوفكا
واكراماتورسك بجمهوريه دنيا الشعبيه
افاد حاكم مقاطعه
الاوكرانيه استهدفت المقاطعه باكثر من
اربعين قذيفه خلال الساعات الاربع
والعشرين الماضيه دون تسجيل خسائر بشريه
او ماديه حسب قوله وفي روسيا ايضا نشرت
وكاله نوفوستي صورا قالت انها لصد القوات
الروسيه محاوله من الجيش الاوكراني
للسيطره على موقع في اتجاه مقاطعه دونيسكو
واجبرت القوات المهاجمه على الانسحاب
وقال موقع العسكريه الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استهدفت احدى المنشات المدنيه
في مقاطعه بيريانسك الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا
واشار الموقع الى ان الموقع المستهدف يقع
على بعد سبعين كيلو مترا من محطه سمول
نيسك للطاقه النوويه وعلق نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي دمت على هذا القصف بالقول
انه في حال تاكد استهدافه محطه سمول نيسك
للطاقه النوويه بصواريخ الناتو من
الضروريه النظر في سيناريو توجيهي ضربه
لمحطه اوكرانيا النوويه والمواقع النوويه
في شرق اوروبا
ينضم الينا من واشنطن لاري كورب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق ومن موسكو
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكما
وابدا معك سيد لاري كورب اذا حسمها الرئيس
بايدن اوكرانيا لن تكون في الناتو قبل
انتهاء الحرب ولكن هذا الامر الا يثير
خيبه الاوكرانيين ويضعف معنوياتهم
في ان هذا يخيب امال الاوكرانيين ولكن اذا
دخلت انضمت اوكرانيا الى الحلف فانه سيكون
على الحلف ان يرد طبقا للماده الخامسه
الشيء الاخر هو انه لكي تصبح عضوا لحلف
الناتو فينبغي ان يكون هناك ديمقراطيه
واوكرانيا ينبغي ان ترى
كان ستصبح دوله ديمقراطيه بعد انتهاء
الحرب ولكن المهم هو ان
تخيب الخيبه الان افضل من الدخول في حرب
هل في ذلك نوع من رسائل الطمانه التي
ارسلها الرئيس بايدن لروسيا من خلال هذا
التصريح
اعتقد ان ما سيحدث هو انهم سوف يقولون
لاوكرانيا عندما تنتهي الحرب نامن ذلك
قريبا بان حتى لا تكون عرضه للهجوم مره
اخرى سوف يتم تعزيز قواتها
والولايات المتحده
تقدم اكثر من مئه
مليون دولار في هذه الحرب وسوف يتم ايضا
نقل قوات قريبه من اوكرانيا الى ليتوانيا
مثلا حتى لو قررت روسيا ان توسع رقعه
هجماتها
وهو ما سوف يكون هناك امكانيه للدفاع عن
تلك البلدان جميعا
كيف تتلقى موسكو هذه التصريحات يعني هذا
امر كان اساسي واحد العناوين المطروحه
لما تسميه روسيا العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا الان الموقف ياتي من الرئيس
بايدن
لاوكرانيا في الناتو قبل انتهاء الحرب
موسكو كيف تفهم هذا الموقف
يفهم هنا في موسكو هو ان اوكرانيا لا
يمكنها ان تصبح عضوا في حلف الناتو لكن
روسيا تريد الاكثر وتريد ضمانات بان ذلك
لن يحدث لان بايدن يقول انه هذا في الوقت
الحاضر ليست جاهزه للدخول لانضمام الى حلف
الناتو ولكن ربما بعد انتهاء الحرب ستنتهي
هذا غير مقبول من قبل الرئيس الروسي
والزعامه الروسيه
يريدون تعهدا كاملا بان اوكرانيا لن تنضم
الى الفنان
من الان حتى
تصل الامور الى مرحله التفاوض الجبهات
مشتعله سيد فيلجن هاور لكن
هل
تاثرت هذه الجبهات بغياب قوات فاجنر
تحديدا في باك موت التي تتقدم فيها من
جديد القوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
الهجمه المضاده الاوكرانيه التي بدات في
صيف لم تكن ناجحه جدا
وروسيا
تتمسك بمواقعها وتامل ان يتم الاحتفاظ
بهذه المواقع الدفاعيه حتى اكتوبر عندما
ياتي
الطقس البارد ويؤثر في العمليات المتحركه
ويمكن بعد ذلك التقدم اكثر وذلك سيكون
انتصارا
استراتيجيا لموسكو لان الطرفين سجل عرف
مشاكل جديه في الامداد بالذخائر
والاسلحه وهذا يعني
بحلول نهايه العام سيكون هناك توقف نوع من
التوقف في المعارك
وروسيا تريد ان
التوقف يكون بشروط
روسيا
واوكرانيا تريد ان تكسر الخطوط
تتحرك
لان ذلك
سيكون موضوعين وهم لا يستطيعون القيام
بذلك حاليا
صيدلاريكورد
بالمعطيات الميدانيه الراهنه هل ما زالت
الولايات المتحده تراهن على تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه مع تعثر الهجوم المضاد كما هو
واضح
الموقف الولايات المتحده في الاساس هو ان
تكون مع اوكرانيا وهدف اوكرانيا الان هو
استعادته جميع الاراضي التي ضمتها روسيا
بشكل غيري قانوني وقد قلنا ان اذا كان ذلك
هو هدف الاوكرانيين فسنستمر في دعمهم لكن
السؤال الحقيقي ماذا عن معنويات الجانب
الروسي مما نسمعه ان هناك العديد من
الجنود غير راضين
وبعضهم يهربون من الجيش
وايضا مع
انحلال المجموعه فاجنر نعم سيكون هناك
تقدم بطيء ولكن السؤال الى كم من الوقت
سيستطيع الروس الصمود
وهناك تقارير بان 200 الف جندي روسي قتلوا
او اصيبوا وكان عليهم ان يدعوا جنود
احتياط الى المشاركه في المعركه ونراه
تقارير عن بعض الجنرالات غير راضين عن
الطريقه التي تسير بها الحرب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه السابق من واشنطن شكرا
جزيلا لك وشكرا لبافل الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كان معنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان ادارته
تتحدث مع الاسرائيليين بانتظام معربا عن
ان يغير نتنياهو
ويتحرك نحو الاعتدال واضاف بايدن في
تصريحات لشبكه
ان اراء بعض اعضاء حكومه نتنياهو بشان
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه تمثل جزءا من
المشكله واكد بايدن انه ما يزال يؤمن بان
حل الدولتين هو سبيل الوحيد لحل الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني وردا على سؤال حول
ما اذا كان نتنياهو سيدعى لزياره البيت
الابيض قال بايدن ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاق هرتزون سيدعى قريبا لزياره واشنطن
[موسيقى]
انا من اولئك الذين يعتقدون ان الامن
النهائي لاسرائيل يكمن في حل الدولتين
حقيقه ان السلطه الفلسطينيه فقدت
مصداقيتها ليس بالضروره بسبب ما فعلت
اسرائيل اسرائيل ليست هي كل المشكله الان
في الضفه الغربيه بل هي جزء منها وخاصه
تلك الاصوات في مجلس الوزراء التي تقول ان
بامكانهم الاستيطان اينما شاؤوا وانه ليس
لدى الفلسطينيين الحق في التواجد هناك نحن
نحاول تهدئه ما يجري ونامل ان يستمر
نتنياهو في التحرك نحو الاعتدال
من جانب قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامينه ياهو ان كل من يقتل اسرائيليين
ويمارسوا الارهاب سيصل الى احد مكانين اما
القبر او السجن على حد تعبيره واضافنا
نتنياهو في مستهل الجلسه الاسبوعيه لمجلس
الوزراء ان حكومته تغير المعادله بما
يستجيب والمص الاسرائيليه على حد قوله
في سياسه حكومتنا ونحن ننفذها بثلاث طرق
اولا نصفي الحساب مع المهاجمين انفسهم دون
استثناء ثانيا نضرب مرسليهم وناشري
الارهاب والبنى التحتيه للارهابيين ثالثا
نحن من يبادر ويباغر نحن من يحدد الزمان
لعملياتنا تماما مثل ما فعلنا في عمليه
الدرع والسهم ضد الجهاد الاسلامي في غزه
ومثل ما فعلنا في عمليه بيت حديقه ضد
المخربين في جنين اننا نغير المعادله وهذا
ما سنواصل القيام به
اما وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
فقال ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه لن توافق على
منح اي مزايا اقتصاديه او ماليه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه وانه لن يتم تحويل اي اموال
ولا تكون هناك تسهيلات ماليه حسب قوله
في غضون ذلك ذكرت صحيفه هاريتس ان اعضاء
المجلس الوزاري الاسرائيلي المصغر لشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه
وافقوا على مقترح قدمه رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو ينص على العمل لمنع
انهيار السلطه الفلسطينيه وذلك مقابل
التزام السلطه بوقت انشطتها ضد اسرائيل في
المحافل السياسيه والقانونيه الدوليه
اضافه الى وقت التحريض في وسائل الاعلام
ومنظومه التعليم كما اشترطت الموافقه على
السلطه وقف الرواتب وصرف الرواتب للعائلات
الفلسطينيه المتهم افرادها بتنفيذ عمليات
ضد اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
الى التطورات في السودان حيث قال مراسل
الجزيره ان الشبكات ضاريا اندلعت بين
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع في
منطقه الكلاكله الجنوبيه الخرطوم واكد
مراسلنا ان دويا انفجارات متتاليه سمع
جنوبي مدينه ام درمان غربيه الخرطوم ومع
اعتدام الاشتباكات في العبيض عاصمه ولايه
شمال كردفان سيطرت قوات الحركه الشعبيه
شمال على معسكر للجيش بمنطقه القرد بولايه
جنوب كردفان هذا هو تحتضن اديس ابابا غدا
اجتماعا للجنه لايجاد الرباعيه بشان
السودان بحضور ممثلين عن الجيش والدعم
السريع
احد اضلاع العاصمه السودانيه الثلاثه
استاثرت في الايام الاخيره بنصيب وافر من
يوميات السودان الداميه فيوم الاحد شهدت
المدينه الواقعه غرب الخرطوم اشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تشهد
السنه اللهب والدخان على قوتها وحدتها حيث
استخدمت فيها مختلف الاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه
احتدام المواجهات في ام درمان يعزى في
جانب كبير منه الى ان الجزء الغربي من
المدينه هو طريق امداد رئيسي لقوات الدعم
السريع لاستقدام التعزيزات من دارفور
معقلها القوي في غرب السودان على ان ايا
من طرفي النزاع لم يبادر الى تعليق القتال
في ام درمان رغم مقتل اكثر من 20 مدنيا
فيها يوم السبت واصابه عشراتنا اخرين في
واحده من اكبر الحوادث دمويه منذ اندلاع
قبل نحو اربعه اشهر
وزاره الصحه السودانيه قالت ان عشرات
القتلى سقطوا في غاره جويه على منطقه
ناهله بالسكان لكن الجيش وهو الجهه
الوحيده التي تمتلك مقاتلات نفى مسؤوليته
عن الحادث متهما قوات الدعم السريع بتظليل
الراي العام عندما نسبت الهجوم لسلاح الجو
السوداني محملا اياها ضمنا المسؤوليه
باعتبارها درجه على قصف المناطق السكنيه
بالمدفعيه والصواريخ وفق بيان الجيش
وقد دفع الحادث الامم المتحده الى التحذير
من ان السودان بات على حافه حرب اهليه
شامله واتهمت المنظمه الدوليه المتحاربين
بتجاهل القانون الانساني وقوانين حقوق
الانسان
اشتباكات الاحاد امتدت الى منطقه الكلاكله
جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم التي هزتها
انفجارات متتاليه سمع دويها جنوب ام درمان
وغربي الخرطوم كما شهدت مدينه الاوبيض غرب
البلاد تبادلا كثيفا لاطلاق النار من
اسلحه ثقيله بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني الذي بدا عمليه انتشار في سوق
المدينه وطالب السكان باخلاء المنطقه
ورغم الاخفاقات المتكرره للهدن في السودان
تنشد الانظار الى العاصمه الاثيوبيه
فهناك تعقيد اللجنه الرباعيه الخاصه
بالازمه السودانيه يوم الاثنين اول اجتماع
لها على مستوى رؤساء الدول والحكومات
المكونه للجنه وهي اثيوبيا وجيبوتي وجنوب
السودان وكينيا ورغم اعتراضات الجيش
السوداني على وساطه الايجاد
واتهامه لها بالانحياز فقد كشفت مصادر
للجزيره ان الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
سيشاركان في الاجتماع
وفضلا عن الاتحاد الافريقي تاكدت مشاركه
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه وممثلين عن السعوديه والامم
المتحده
انضموا الينا هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السودانيه دكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم مرحبا بك دكتور لنبدا باجتماع
الايجاد
اللجنه الرباعيه على مستوى الرؤساء
غدا في اديس ابا هل يمكن ان يخرج شيء
ايجابي
السودان لديه موقف معلن من هذه المبادره
حيث رفض ابتداء رئاسه الرئيس الكيني
للجنه الرباعيه المكونه من رؤساء
جنوب السودان واثيوبيا وكينيا
جيبوتي
وحسب المعلومات التي رشحت فقط نورس ضغوط
كبيره على الجيش السوداني قياده الجيش
السوداني كي يشارك بوط في هذا اللقاء
وسيشارك وسيشارك لكنه لن يقبل بحسب ما
تاكد لنا لن يقبل برئاسه كينيا للجنه وانه
اذا اصرت الايجاد على استمرار ويلي في
رئاسه اللجنه فسيغادر الوفد السوداني
الاجتماع فوق ذلك هناك جهات اخرى ستشارك
في هذا الاجتماع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والسعوديه باعتبارها
المسهلان الرئيسيان للمبادره التي
استضافتها مدينه جده السعوديه واشتغلت على
تفاهمات واتفاقيات وقعت موقف ضغوط على
الجيش كي يشارك في هذا الاجتماع حسب علمي
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي طلبت من
الجيش السوداني ان يشارك وان يدلي اتعاف
وزارته سيما على المقترحات التي قدمها
الرئيس الكيني المعروف بصيلاته تجاريه مع
قائد قوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده على
الجيش السوداني
ومنها ان الموقف غير متوازن وان الخطه
التي اقترحها لم تعرض اصلا السودان ولم
يتم التنسيق معه حولها ومن تفاصيلها ان
يتم اخلاء العاصمه السودانيه من القوات ما
الذي سيتم بحثه غدا ما الذي سيطرح هذه
الخطه التي تتحدث عنها هي التي ستطرح في
هذا الاجتماع يفترض ذلك التفاصيل الخطه
تتحدث عن وقف فوري لاطلاق النار اخراج
القوات المسلحه
جيش او الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم مع
محيطه 50 كيلومترا
واصناعه امر الاشراف على الامن داخل
المدينه للشرطه
جهاز الامن السوداني
النائب رئيس السودان
مجلس السياده السوداني مالك عقار وصف هذه
الخطه بانها تمثل الانتهاكا
يعني هي مرفوضه سلفا من الجيش الخطه
مرفوضه ورئاسه ايضا مرفوضه الميدانيه
اصبحت المعارك في في السودان في الخرطوم
تحديدا بمدونه ثلاث اصبحت
بشكل شبه يومي لكن ماذا عن شمال كردفان
ماذا عن التحرك الذي قامت به
الحركه الشعبيه شمال
في شمال كردفان حاولت قوات الدعم السريع
ان تهاجم مدينه الرويضه اليوم وتصدت لها
حاميه المدينه الهجانه وكبدتها خسائر
كبيره وتعرضتها الى خارج المدينه
ودمرت مجموعه من مركباتها العسكريه واثرت
عشر سيارات من قوات الحركه سيطرت على موقع
للجيش الحركه الشعبيه ظلت خلال الفتره
الماضيه تحاول استغلال الظرف الذي يعاني
منه الجيش السوداني من شغاله في عده جبهات
لكي تمارس ما اصطلح على تسميته سياسه شد
الاطراف لمنعه من سحب اي قوات من مناطق
التماس مع الحركه الشعبيه اما على الصعيد
السياسي فلديه اضافه بسيطه اعتقد ان الجيش
السوداني
يواجه ضغوط كبيره من قواعده في السودان
بعدم الدخول في اتفاقات جديده ما لم يتم
ما تم تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه ثابتا
سابقا اتضحت الفكره الدكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم شكرا جزيلا لك اشكرك
ومعنا من ابوجا ديفيد اوتو اندلي مدير
مركز
جنيد للامن والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في
افريقيا مرحبا بك سيد اندلي اذن
ما قاله ضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
مزمل هو رفض رئاسه روتو لهذه اللجنه رئاسه
كينيا للجنه الوساطه وايضا رفض للخطه التي
يقدمها اذا كيف يمكن ان
تتحرك اي وساطه في ظل رفض الجيش الصارم
لذلك
هذا هو التحدي الذي تواجهه لجنه
الازمه خاصه في هذا الاجتماع في اثيوبيا
القوات المسلحه السودانيه
تقول ان كينيا كانوا
قريبين من قوات الدعم السريع والديهم
مصلحه ولذلك هناك تضارب مصالح
اذا ليس لديهم قابليه
بان تكون كينيا طرفا في هذه اللجنه
وخاصه في رئاستها
ولكن اعتقد
ان مصلحه
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه تدفع
الممثلين القوات المسلحه السودانيه على
الحضور وهي حركه جيده لكن ينبغي ان نتذكر
انه حتى اذا كانت الزعمت تقول انها لا
تفهم
اجنده هذه هذا الاجتماع
فان لديه اجندتين هو وقف العنف
السماح بايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لكن
يبدو ان هذا من الصعب ان ينجح يعني حتى
هذا الاجتماع
هو اجتماع لبحث ما يشبه الهدنه بما يماثل
الهدن السابقه ولن يكون على جندته اي
موضوع سياسي او له علاقه بحل الازمه بين
الطرفين
هذا هو ما تم الاتفاقه عليه انهم يقومون
بالشيء نفسه وقد يحصرون على نتائج نفسها
اي ان الطرفين لن يحترم وقف اطلاق النار
حتى لو اتفق على وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وما يقومون به في الوقت الحاضر هو ضمان
لا يسمح باستخدام هذه
الهدنات
لتعزيز مواقع لم نرى اي فاعليه في
المفاوضات
بما في ذلك التي كان وراءها الامارات
وكان السعوديه
المتحده لنرى فارقا الى حد الان لم نرى اي
مفاوضات سلام طيب ما فائده عفوا
قبل ان يداهمنا الوقت سيد اندلي ما ما
فائده هذا الاجتماع اذا اجتماع اديس ابابا
غدا اذا كان
محكوم عليه بالفشل كما هو واضح
هي انه حتى لو ان هذا الاجتماع قد يفشل
فلا ينبغي ان نتوقف عن المفاوضات ربما ان
الطرفين يشعر بالتعب
ونقصت لديه كميات الذخائر والاسلحه او
يغير
رايهما وياتي الى المفاوضات لان هذه الحرب
مستمره منذ وقت طويل ربما ليس لم يعد
لديهما اسلحه الكافيه اذا في مرحله ما
سيكون عليهما ان يدخل مفاوضات ولكن لا
اعتقد انني ارى اي فارق بين هذا الاجتماع
وما والمحاولات التي حدثت من قبل
شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد
ديفيد اوتو اندلي مدير مركز جنيف للامن
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا حدثنا
من ابو جا
[موسيقى]
قال الدفاع المدني السوري في مناطق
المعارضه ان خمسه مدنيين بينهم طفل قتلوا
واصيب ثلاثه جراء انفجار سياره مفخخه قرب
ورشه صيانه سيارات في قريه شوا بمنطقه
الراعي في ريف حلب الشرقي
[موسيقى]
اكدت مصادر قضائيه بولايه صفاقس جنوب تونس
فقدان عشره مهاجرين غير نظاميين تونسيين
وانتشال جثه واحده بعد غرق مركبهم على
سواحل جرجيس مساء السبت مما يرفع عدد
القتلى الى اكثر من 600 منذ بدايه العام
وفتحت النيابه العامه باسفاقس تحقيقا
للكشف عن ملابسات الحادث من جانب طلب مدير
الجانب الليبي لمعبر راس جدير بين ليبيا
وتونس اللواء عبد السلام العمراني طالب
سلطات التونسيه بابعاد طالب اللجوء
الافارقه القادمين من تونس عن النقطه
الحدوديه الليبيه لاسباب امنيه
حلم وصول هؤلاء من طالبي اللجوء الى
اوروبا يسبقه حلم اخر هو الوصول الى البحر
قبل خوضهم غمار رحله قد يكون مصير من
يخوضها الغراق عند معبر راس جدير بين تونس
وليبيا وصل طالب لجوء جلبهم السلطات
التونسيه استنادا الى مدير الجانب الليبي
للمعبر طالب المسؤول الليبي تونس بابعادهم
عن المعبر لاسباب امنيه وقبل يومين طالبت
منظمه
تونس بوضع حد لما وصفتها بعمليه الطرد
الجماعي لطالبي لجوء افارقه نحو منطقه
صحراويه نائيه قرب الحدود مع ليبيا نقلت
المنظمه شهادات بعضهم عن وفاه مهاجرين
وقتل اخرين برصاص الجيش التونسي اما السبب
الترحيل وفقا لما ذكرته مصادر اعلاميه يا
اعلى خلفيه اضطرابات شهدتها مدينه صفاقس
التونسيه بعد قيام افريقي بقتل مواطن
تونسي اذا تشهد كل من ليبيا وتونس موجات
لطامحين بالوصول الى اوروبا
ياتي معظم هؤلاء مما تعرب بالدول افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء عبر شبكات تهريب تتولى نقلهم
برا يفضل بعضهم اتخاذ شواطئ تونس منطلقا
لرحلته لقربها من جزر ايطاليه لا تبعد
اكثر من 150 كيلومترا
ويبدو اتساع مساحه ليبيا وما تشهده من وضع
حالي ممر يسهل الوصول الى شواطئها غير
البعيده ايضا عن الجزر الايطاليه
يفرها هؤلاء من بلدانهم في رحله الشقاء
هذه لاسباب كثيره منها الحرب والمجاعه
وانعدام الامل في واقع افضل وهم في ازدياد
لا نقصان لا اعداد رسميه دقيقه بشان من
يصلون تونس وليبيا لكن واستنادا الى تقاري
الاعلاميه فان ايطاليا سجلت هذا العام
زياده في الواصلين الى شواطئها بلغوا اكثر
من 60 الف شخص بزياده قدرها
133% مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من العام
الماضي على الضفه الاخرى من البحر من
اوروبا تحرك قاده دول ومنظمات للتنسيق مع
السلطات التونسيه بهدف تعزيز قدراتها على
ضبط حدودها البريه والبحريه وضمان تمويل
بملايين اليوروهات سنويا
ساتزود تونس وفق المشروع الاوروبي بقوارب
وارادارات النقاله وكاميرات مراقبه
يسعى الاوروبيون كذلك الى تسهيل عوده
التونسيين مقيمين في اوروبا بشكل غير
نظامي
فتونس نفسها شهدت وتشهد محاوله طلب اللجوء
عبر القوارب من ابنائها ومنذ سنوات بدات
او لنقل ازدادت وتيرتها مع سوء الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه
وتشارك عشرات التونسيين مع غيرهم مغامره
ركوب القوارب ومحاوله عبور البحر فلاقوا
المصير نفسه نجاه او غرقا
معنى من مدينه جرجيس في الجنوب التونسي
مراسله الجزيره ميساء الفطناسي ميساء
مرحبا بك كيف تبدو هذه المدينه في ضوء
ازمه اللجوء هذه وكيف تتعاطى معها السلطات
التونسيه مع انتشال جثه احد المهاجرين غير
النظاميين
عما حسن هنا في مدينه جرجيس هذه المدينه
المتاخمه
مدينه بن قردان التي تقع على الحدود
التونسيه الليبيه يتحدث سكان المدينه عن
مظاهر جديده وعن ظاهره جديده ربما اصبحوا
يشاهدونها يوميا خلال الايام الماضيه
وتحديدا منذ بدا ازمه المهاجرين في مدينه
صفاقس هذه الظاهره تتمثل في عشرات
المهاجرين من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
الذين يعبرون مدينه جرجيس يوميا فرادى او
جماعات متجهين الى حدود التونسيه الليبيه
التي تبعد حوالي 80 كيلومترا من هذه
المنطقه ومن هذه المدينه مدينه جرجيس
هؤلاء المهاجرين وخلال رحلتهم من صفاقس
الى المناطق الحدوديه المناطق الحدوديه
البريه بين تونس
يواجهون ظروفا انسانيه وصحيه صعبه
التفتت اليها او بدا الالتفات اليها بعد
الصور وبعد التقارير التي نشرت حول حالات
اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء المهاجرين خلال هذه
الرحله الطويله التي يقومون بها مشيا على
الاقدام مئات الكيلومترات نتحدث عنها هنا
يقومون بها هؤلاء في درجات حراره مرتفعه
اليوم منظمه الهلال الاحمر التونسي وبعد
حديث الرئيس سعيد امس مع رئيسها عن ضروره
توجه وفد من منظمه الهلال الاحمر الى
المناطق الحدوديه الفاصله بين تونس وليبيا
لتفقد حاله المهاجرين الذين الذين يعتبرون
يعتبرون عالقين في تلك المنطقه توجه اليوم
وفد من الهلال الاحمر التونسي الى هناك
وكانت هناك صور ق نشرت عن هذه الزياره
باعتبار انها يبدو انها كانت بعيده او دون
حضور وسائل الاعلام ودون حضور عدسات
الكاميرا وبالتالي تحدث منذ قليل في
قناه الرسميه التونسيه تحدث رئيس المنظمه
عن هذه الزياره التي قاموا بها
لاعداد المهاجرين العالقين على الحدود
البريه بين تونس وليبيا قال انهم كانوا في
ظروف صعبه وان
الهلال الاحمر التونسي حاول ان يوفر لهم
المدد من الماء وغذاء وغيره وتحدث ايضا عن
بعض الحالات التي تطلب نقلها الى المستشفى
المحلي ببن قردان
للقيام بالفحوصات الصحيه اللازمه وتحدث عن
ان حاله من بين هؤلاء ما زالت تتلقى
العلاج في المستشفى باعتبار انه يعاني من
كسر انفساقه وايضا تحدث عن ان عمل منظمه
الهلال الاحمر ستتواصل خلال الايام
القادمه بهذه المنطقه وعن ظروف وعن مطالب
المهاجرين هناك قال بان عدد كبير منهم عبر
عن رغبته في العوده طوعيا الى بلدانهم
تقريبا عددهم 150 شخصا ممن
عبروا عن رغبتهم في العوده الى بلدانهم
وتحدث عن
مساعي وتنسيق لمنظمه الهلال الاحمر مع
بقيه المنظمات الدوليه الحقوقيه لتامين
عوده هؤلاء الى بلدانهم بشكل طوعي من
مدينه جرجيس في الجنوب التونسي مراسله
الجزيره مساء الفطناسي شكرا جزيلا لك
وقال عدد من اللاجئين الافارقه العليقين
منذ ايام على الخط الحدودي الفاصل بين
ليبيا وتونس انهم يرغبون في الدخول الى
الاراضي الليبيه او السماح لهم بعبور
البحر نحو اوروبا
ويتجاوز عدد هؤلاء اللاجئين 700 شخص وهم
يعانون من نقص كبير في الماء والغذاء
نحن الان عند الخط الحدودي الفاصل بين
ليبيا وتونس حيث يتجمع مئات من المهاجرين
او اللاجئين غير النظاميين ابلغونا ان
عددهم يفوق السبع مئه لاجئ من عده دول
افريقيه من دول جنوب الصحراء هؤلاء
اللاجئون يقولون انهم ابعدوا من الاراضي
التونسيه ابعدتهم السلطات التونسيه باتجاه
الاراضي الليبيه وايضا يقولون انهم الان
لا يريدون سوى العوده الى بلادهم او
بلدانهم او مساعدتهم في ركوب البحر
والوصول الى الجزر الايطاليه ومنها الى
ومنها الى القاره الاوروبيه هؤلاء
المهاجرون او اللاجئون اخبرونا ان اوضاعهم
الانسانيه متفاقمه بشكل كبير وان اوضاعهم
الانسانيه تتفاقم كل يوم ويقول انهم لا
يملكون الماء والغذاء هؤلاء اللاجئون ايضا
يطالبون بايجاد حلول سريعه لهم لانتشالهم
من هذه المعاناه التي يعيشونها بين الحدود
او على الحدود الليبيه التونسيه يناشدون
السلطات الليبيه لادخالهم الى الاراضي
الليبيه عندما راى هؤلاء اللاجئون راوا
كاميرا الجزيره كانوا يصرخون نريد ليبيا
نريد ليبيا واكدوا لنا في احاديثهم انهم
لا يريدون العوده من حيث اتوا من الاراضي
التونسيه وانما يريدون العبور الى الاراضي
الليبيه او الوصول الى القاره الاوروبيه
او العوده بهم الى بلدانهم ويقولون ان
اوضاعهم الانسانيه تتفاقم كل يوم احمد
خليفه الجزيره من الخط الحدودي الفاصل بين
ليبيا وتونس
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في فقره المتابعه الليله نركز
على التوتر المتزايد في البلقان اذا دخل
قانوناني مثيران للجدل وقعهما رئيس صرب
البوسنه
دخلها حيزه تنفيذ اليوم بعد ان وقع عليهما
الجمعه احد القانونين يلغي سلطه الممثل
السامي الدولي داخل الكيان الصربي في
جمهوريه البوسنه والهرسك ويمثل هذا تحديا
كبيرا للممثل الدولي الذي يشرف على تطبيق
اتفاقيات دايتون للسلام التي انهت الحرب
في البوسنه والهرسك هذه الحرب من عام
1992 وحتى 1995
وهي تمتع الممثل الثاني الدولي بسلطات
تنفيذيه مهمه لاسيما فيما يتعلق باقاله
مسؤولين منتخبين وفردي قوانين هناك شق اخر
من القانون يعلق اعتراف الكيان الصربي
بقوانين اصدرتها المحكمه الدستوريه
الروسيه ووقع القانونين بعد ايام فقط على
محاوله الممثل السامي الدولي اسقاط هذه
الخطوات عبر اصدار امر
تنفيذيا يعتبرهما لاغيين ويمنع تطبيقهما
[موسيقى]
ومنذ الحرب في تسعينيات القرن العشرين
قسمت البوسنه الى كيانين كما هو معروف
احدهما صربي والاخر كرواتيه بوسني تجمع
بينهما مؤسسات مركزيه ضعيفه
واثارت مبادرات الكيان الصربي ردود فعل
مندده من جانب قاده مسلمين بوسنيين ما
ينذر بمزيد من التوترات في الدوله الواقعه
في البلقان والمنقسمه طائفيا كما انتقد اه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن
هذه الخطوه وقال انها تنتهك دستور البوسنه
والهرسك وتقود اتفاقات دايتون للسلام في
المقابل كانت روسيا الحليف الرئيسي لصرب
البوسنه اقترحت في يوليو عام 2021 على
مجلس الامن مشروع قرار ينص على اغلاق مكتب
المبعوث الدولي لكن المشروع الروسي الذي
شاركت الصين في رعايته لقي رفضا بمجلس
الامن بعد ان اتهم دبلوماسيون غربيون
موسكو بالرغبه في تقويض الدور الامم في
جمهوريه البوسنه والهرسك معنا من
كوزلاك استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والمتخصص
في شؤون البلقان مرحبا بك
ماذا بعد دخول هذين القانونين حيز التنفيذ
ماذا سيحصل معنى
يتضمناه من امور هامه وخطيره في الوقت
ذاته
السيد
الصرب
في البوسنه
قاموا بهجوما على
اتفاق السلام
وهو يضمن الامن وسلامه اراضي البوسنه
والهرسك كعضو كامل العضويه في الامم
المتحده قبل اسبوع
دوديك الذي قاد جميع هذه الانشطه
غير الدستوريه
قام بضغوط من اجل تبني هذا القانون
لمنع
عملي المندوب الممثل الدولي في البوسنه
والهرسك
والممثل الدوليه والسامي
واذا سوف يحاول ان
يلغي هذه ولكن ايضا سيتم التوجه الى
المحكمه المحكمه الجنائيه ويعتبرها عملا
اجراميا وهذا مهم في المستقبل لان ما حدث
بالامس هو انه اجبر السلطه المحليه ووقع
قرارا ثم
اجبر السلطات المحليه لكي
تدخله حيز التنفيذ في شكل قانون
حتى حتى عفوا عفوا حتى تتضح الصوره اكثر
هو الان الرئيس صربي الغى
هذا المنصب
وعمليا ليست هناك صلاحيات وفقا لهذا
القانون للممثل الدولي السامي طيب كيف
سيتم الرد دوليا الامم المتحده كيف سترد
على هذا القرار وهو لم يعد لديه صلاحيات
بموجب القانون الصربي
هذا امر فيه الكثير من التحدي نعم
والمجتمع الدولي الان يمكن ان يرد الفعل
ضد السلطات المحليه او المجتمع الدولي
يمكن ان من خلال
ممثل السامي
لاعاده تمكينه
من استخدام السلطاته
وتلك الخطوه يمكن ان
يتم تمكينه من المجتمع الدولي بصلاحيات
لالغاء هؤلاء السياسيين من الساحه
السياسيه
لكن يمكن ان يتم ذلك ايضا بالتعامل مع
السلطات المحليه
لان
ممثل السامي
ادخل تغييرات في المحكمه الجنائيه والمدعي
العام يمكن ان يرد الفعل الان
ويامر
مصالحه
بتقديم ذلك المسؤول الى المحاكمه وهم
معاقبته طبقا للقانون الجديد طيب فاذا
يعني عفوا عفوا المساله المساله هنا
مرتبطه بالمحكمه
وبالشخصيات التي سبق ان عينها اصلا
الممثل الدوله السامي لكن اذا اخذناها
بالبعد الاوسع هل هذا انتصار لروسيا
على الولايات المتحده باختصار ارجوك
هذه نقطه مهمه جدا لان جميع هذه الاعمال
التي قام بها السيد دودي تمت بالتنسيق مع
الاتحاد الروسي
وسلطاتها وخاصه
الاستخبارات اذا المجتمع الدولي اذا لم
يرد بسرعه
فسيكون ذلك انتصارا للاتحاد الروسي
ا العلاقات الدوليه والمتخصص في شؤون
البلقان من سراييفو شكرا جزيلا
لهذا مشاهدينا ناتي الى نهايه الحصاد لهذه
الليله تصبح هنا على الف خير
[موسيقى]